uncharted 4 launched in May and the
multiplayer side of Nathan Drake's final
adventure is still going strong in fact
the first multiplayer DLC pack is out
right now lost treasures comes to
uncharted 4 via the games 1 point 0 8
update which means everyone gets it for
free lost treasures brings a ton of new
content including the small arena like
sunken ruins map there are also several
new weapons and boosters plus a new path
of Indra mystical which lets you
teleport to any Ally tons of new vanity
items can be found in the store to over
50 new skins and 70 new hat and face
items to be exact the patch itself also
adds a new leveling system to
multiplayer with each rank earning you
unique items it also revamps ranked team
deathmatch to make the mode run in
seasons a few balance changes and weapon
fixes are also baked into the update
lost treasures is the first of four
plans multiplayer DLC packs for
uncharted 4 with the others coming this
autumn winter 2017 and spring 2017
developer Naughty Dog has also mentioned
single-player DLC but currently has
nothing to announce when they do you can
be sure you'll hear about it from
GameSpot